on va passer aux invités du soir on va
évoquer cette disparition très
inquiétante cette disparition
inquiétante de mellodie mendz Da Silva
une marseillaèse de 34 ans qui est
introuvable depuis 2 semaine jour pour
jour après un dernier message à sa sœur
sur snapchat cette mère de famille n'a
plus donné aucun signe de vie alors
qu'aucun élément n'aurait pu justifier
une disparition volontaire la
disparition est jugée extrêmement
inquiétante par les autorités elle est
surtout insoutenable pour ses proches
ils sont avec nous ce soir peurle son
mari est là et Patrick son frère sont
avec nous regardez cette info desjt et
ils seront avec nous juste après il y
aura également Pierre-Henry bovis avocat
pénalis qui va nous expliquer ce qui se
passe actuellement c'est parti partout
dans la ville le mari de mélodyie
affiche ses avis de recherche son épouse
a disparu depuis le 3 novembre de
semaines sans nouvelles de
l'esthéticienne de 34 ans le 3 novembre
dernier Melody aurait quitté son
domicile vers 17h c'est 3 jours plus
tard que son mari se rend au
commissariat une enquête pour
disparition inquiétante a été ouverte
par le parquet de Marseille merci pear
d'être avec nous merci beaucoup vous
êtes le mari de mellody c'est une
histoire qu'on suit depuis le 3 novembre
c'est une histoire complètement folle
vous allez nous raconter ce qui s'est
passé le 3 novembre elle sort de la
maison dans le 4e arrondissement de
Marseille il est 18h15 18h15 ça allait
bien elle était énervée elle était
comment quand bah part le décès de sa
mère d'accord c'était cétait quand
c'était le 12 octobre d'accord elle est
partie l'enterrer au pays au d'accord
elle est revenue le 28 octobre à la
maison quand elle est revenue donc elle
se renferm en elle j'ai pas trop voulu
la brousquer parce que je sais ce que
c'est moi-même j'ai perdu mon père il y
a quelques années ouais
donc c'est pas une chose facile perdre
un parent
elle a envoyé un message à sa sœur
Sabrina 18h43 une note vocale sur snap
c'est ça disit quoi elle lui disait que
si elle voulait la contacter qu'elle
appelait parce que sa sœur est enceinte
donc du
coup voilà elle était disponible si elle
avait besoin d'elle vous étiez où vous à
ce moment-là moi j'étais au travail
d'accord donc pour pour vous aucune
raison de s'inquiéter pour moi aucune
raison de m'inquiéter alors sauf que
vous n'avez très vite plus de réponse
pas de nouvelles ben je l'ai appelé à
19h15 ouais son téléphone a sonné ouais
je me suis dit qu'elle allait me
rappeler une demi-heure plus tard son
téléphone avait toujours enfin il avait
plus il était éteint quoi à quel moment
vous avez commencé à vous inquiéter
ben dans les alentour de 22h j'ai j'ai
j'ai contacté sa sœur pour savoir sielle
était avec elle j'ai essayé de voir de
mon côté si je pouvais savoir où est-ce
qu'elle était et le lendemain encore
plus et plus les jour est passé au plus
je m'inquiétais vous essayez de la
rappeler plusieurs fois c'est ça
toujours pas et un moment vous dit il y
a un problème il y a un gros problème
surtout qu'elle est sortie sans rien
sans rien elle avait seulement les
téléphone avec elle euh vous appelez
tous les hôpitaux les commissa les
hôpitaux je me suis déplacé dans les
hôpitaux montré la photo je j'ai essayé
de voir pour les commissariat si était
pas en garde à vue je supposais toutes
les chose qu' pouvit avoir et rien rien
aucune nouvelle aucune nouvelle dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi comment vous
avez comment com vous êtes dans quel
état parce que c'est incroyable vous
dites j'avais ma ma femme elle part à
18h40
elle reviens pas je me retrouve 7 nuis
tout seul comment c'était quoi tour dans
le lit je tournais dans le lit je me je
me posais plein de questions je me
demandais qu'est-ce qui se
passait essayz vous étiez à côté de
votre téléphone vous av dit peut-être
elle va téléphone téléphone en plein
sonnerie euh les 30 secondes je quand je
me levais je regardais le téléphone si
j'avais pas reçu un appel alors euh
elle disparaît le vendredi donc le
samedi vous la cherchez partout rien
rien dimanche pareil vous vous vous vous
appelez la police le lundi je vais chez
la police le lundi oui pourquoi parce
que on m'avait dit que c'était 48h pour
déclarer une disparition inquiétante
d'accord c'est-à-dire que vous êes dit
Avanton ça servait à rien parce que il
vous aurz dit elle va revenir peut-être
voà donc vous attendez 48h ces 48h on
devait être une éternité c bment euh
vous allez à la police vous vous dites
quoi ben je leur déclar la disparition
que je leur dis qu'elle est sortie sans
rien sans aucun papier ouais il a été en
claquette il é habillé tout en
noir les les policiers vous disent quoi
ils me disent écoutez ben on va
transférer le dossier parce que je suis
parti dans le 10e arrendissement pour le
faire la déclaration d'accord donc ils
ont transféré le dossier sur Noï le
lendemain j'ai été contacté par la
police qui ont pu voir que le téléphone
avait borné la dernière fois dans le 11e
arrondissement à 19h24 d'accord mais bon
un bnage c'est vaste ça ça donne pas un
point fixe incroyable donc là 19h24
c'est la dernière fois qu'on a des
nouvelles de de mélodie il même pas des
nouvelles c'est téléphone é allumé
exactement c'est la dernière fois qu'on
a un semblant de de
nouvell persuadé qu'elle allait rentrer
pour la rentrée scolaire de des enfants
c'est ça c'était le lundi c'était le
lundi ou mais pourquoi pour un moment
quand vous dites vous étiez persuadé
qu'elle est rentré pour rentréol enfant
estce qu' moment vous êtes dit
peut-êtreelle elle a comme avec le décès
de sa maman quelques semaines plus tôt
tout ça vous dites peut-être elle a elle
a voulu un petit peu faire le le vide
c'est ça d'être un peu seul vers le vide
ce que je me suis dit c le meilleur des
cas pour moi à ce momentl
mais c'est vrai que là vous vous
attendez vous attendez et est-ce que la
police a pris tout de suite l'affaire au
sérieux non non au début ils vous ont
dit quoi bah il m' ré spéciale bon ils
m'ont appelé le lendemain donc je pense
que quand même ils ont un peu pris au
sérieux ils ont commencé à faire leurs
recherches
euh après j'ai vu que les choses ont
vraiment bougé cé à partir de samedi je
crois que ns le 11 11 jours après non on
était le 11 donc ça faisait 8 jours mi
jours mais c'est vrai parce que
seulement 11 jours après une enquête
pour disparition inquiétante est ouverte
par le parquet de Marseille c'est ça
seulement 11 jours après Gill est-ce que
c'est c'est la procédure non le délai
est trop long et les premières heures
sont fondamentales dans une affaire de
disparition donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
déjà le weekend où la police n'est pas
alertée je comprends tout à fait vos
préoccupations puis après il y a
plusieurs jours où la police ne tente
pas de la de la rechercher donc c'est
très compliqué est-ce que est-ce que
justement est-ce que PEL aurait dû aller
voir tout de suite la police même si
c'était avant 48h ou pas alors
l'histoire des 48h on a ça dans la tête
mais en fait on on peut y aller avant
vous auriez pu je vais pas dire vous
auriez dû juge absolument pas vous
auriez pu mais est-ce que la police à ce
moment-là très vite aurait dit mais
attendez ça maman vient de décéder elle
est peut-être pas bien elle a besoin de
s'er la tête je sais pas si ça aurait
changé fondamentalement moi j'ai une
question à vous poser parce que quand
elle sort de chez vous on le voit sur la
vidéosurveillance elle est elle est en
tong elle a pas d'affaires sur son
téléphone est-ce qu'il y a un motif à
cette sortie est-ce qu'elle sort pour
voir quelqu'un voir une amie est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose qui c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose et
vous aussi et vous n'avez pas de réponse
non d'accord elle est pas sorti pour une
raison que l'on connaît en tout cas pas
moi si quelqu'un est le sait je sais en
tout cas c'est pas moi et je pense
qu'une personne serait venue me voir
depuis le temps bien sûr
j'espère les enquêteurs ils vous disent
quoi peur ils me disent plus rien ils
sont sur l'enquête ils peuvent plus me
divulguer ser même un indice ou même une
information alors on va revenir sur les
éléments qui intriguent avec Pierre
Henry bovis notamment et avec Gill donc
comme vous l'avez dit vous apprenez que
le bornage du téléphone il a été borné
pour la dernière fois dans le 11e
arrondissement de Marseille à 19h24 euh
est-ce qu'elle avait quelque chose à
faire dans ce 11e arrondissement de
Marseille ou pas du tout pas que je
sache que sa c'est pas un secteur qu'on
fréquente souvent nous on est dans le 4e
c'est pas très très loin mais c'est pas
à côté vous avz aucun proche qui habite
dans le quartier avait pas d'amis là-bas
il y a son père qui habite là-bas mais
son père était au pays à ce moment-là
d'accord donc euh
ouis est-ce que vous avez vous avez
également comme la dit Gile pu voir
avoir des nouvelles de des images de de
vidéos de surveillance de l'immeuble euh
et dessus est-ce qu'elle a l'air elle
elle a l'air dans quel état euh sur les
vidéos de sur elle a l' hésitante
hésitante d'cord elle a l'air hésitante
donc moi quand j'ai pu récupérer la
vidéo je l'ai vite ramener à la police
le plus rapidement possible et on la
voit sur les caméras vidéo surveillance
de la ville pas du tout est-ce qu'on a
pu la retracer pas à ma connaissance
pour le moment pour le moment il y a
cette dernière image puis comme vous
dites le bornage et l'appel à sa sœur
mais il y a pas d'autres traces à ma
connaissance peêre apparemment ils V
train de les utiliser hein voilà les
enquêteurs ils ont déjà des images de
vidéos a priori c'est je suis pas
certain que ça été enregistré sur
Marseille mais ça permettrait
effectivement de suivre son trajet parce
qu'il y a une absence totale ça sera
important oui c'est sera important très
important au niveau du travail elle
travaillait ça allait bien oui ça allait
très bien très bien elle était en train
de monter un institut de beauté avec sa
sœur c'est ça donc c'était son projet
donc elle était à fond dans son projet
donc il y a pas deu qui est dans ma rue
donc pas besoin d'aller très très
loin et comme vous l'avez dit voilà
niveau perso ça allit un petit peu Mo
bien je l'ai vu que ça l'a vraiment ça
l'a vraiment touché la mor de Samar bien
sûr la disparition ça chose normal man
elle était comment depuis depuis depuis
DC est-ce est-ce qu'elle vous a dit
quelque chose est-ce qu'elle vous a dit
à un moment j'ai envie de tout lâcher
j'ai envie de est-ce qu'il y a eu des
signes ou pas du tout non seu chose que
je voyais qu'elle elle se renfermait
beaucoup elle avait pas envie de sortir
pas envie de parler avec les gens
elle se
renferm vous avez deux enfants avec M
ils ont 15 et 9 ans vous imaginez bien
le dans quel état ils sont actuellement
euh comment ils ont réagi comment vous
expliquez ça à vos enfants j'y Arve pas
vous y arrivez pas c'est impossible'est
sa même pas quoi leur dire oui c'est ça
ils vous disent quoi vous disent elle
est où
maman B les premiers jours oui ouais
donc je savais pas trop quoi leur
répondre leur disait quoi elle va
revenir on oui oui je je les rassurer au
maximum en leant qu'elle va revenir bien
sûr mais là temp le temps pass c'est de
plus en plus ils doivent se poser des
questions ils m'en parlent même pas
eux-même là ils savent à 9 et 15 ans ils
savent maintenant qu'il a est ENF qu' a
pour l'instant on sait pas où aller et
ils vous disent des choses ils vous
disent papa on il m'en parle pas c'est
vrai c'est vraiment il n'en parle pas du
tout non il doivent être dans une
tristesse absolue c'est c'est même pour
vous ça doit être très très compliqué de
de de de gérer ça aussi j'imagine qui me
maintiennne debout ouais c'est ça ouais
aujourd'hui je vous vois vraiment bah
c'est normal très très affecté
et on on se met à votre place on se dit
je sais pas comment on aurait réagi
parce que comme ça une disparition du
jour au lendemain aucune nouvelle les
deux enfants à la maison je sais pas
comment vous trouvez les mots comment
vous trouvez la force pour dans mes
enfants c'est eu qui me permettent de
marcher aujourd'hui c'est eux qui me
font avancer et continuer à chercher
leur MRE vous y croyez j'y crois vous
continuer les recherches bien entendu
euh est-ce que vos enfants il vous dit
qu'ils en parlent pas euh parce que je
sais qu' la plus grande lit tout sur les
réseaux sociaux donc forcément elle sait
que c'est un où on la recherche de
partout
euh est-ce qu'ils ont pu retourner à
l'école et cetera ou ben je préfère les
préserver parce que malheureusement on
vu dans un monde où beaucoup peuvent se
moquer de ce genre de situation
exactement exactement c'est extrê moi
j'ai reçu des appels horribles non
vraiment ouis de gens quoi qui faisaient
genre ben elle elle est allongée devant
moi elle est en train de pleurer je suis
à tel endroit en numéro masqué bien sûr
hein quelle B des gens qui m' appelé
pour me dire oui bonjour c'est pour
commander de la viande
hachée quoi ah non mais vraiment il y a
vraiment des abrutisusez-moi de dire ça
franchement j'ai vraiment on est
vraiment dans un monde d'abru Mo Jes mon
numéro parce que je suis inquiet par
rapport à ma compagne bien sûr il y a
des mecs qui font des blagues mais c'est
c'est pas un parmi tant d'autres oui
mais bon même un c'est c'est
inadmissible excusez-moi jeimagine
dansquelétat vous êtes actuellement plus
j' imagine que dès que vous entendez le
téléphone sonner dès que vous avez un
appel un numéro que vous connaissez pas
c'est
ça B nouelle ou c'est peut-être une
bonne nouvelle donc je réponds à tous
les appels euh Pierre Henry bovis euh il
faut prévenir la police tout de suite
dans ce cas-là ou pas c'est ce que
disait Gill verd c'est que c'est très
c'est très difficile à juger si vous
voulez et et en plus il faut absolument
pas faire culpabiliser qui que ce soit
là et la la peine est immense mais mais
ce qui est vrai c'est que lorsqu'on a
une
disparition qui est subite qui est
inexplicable que ce soit par le contexte
que ce soit par la manière dont la
personne part sans aucune raison sans
affaires ni rien on est dans tous les
critères qui caractérisent la
disparition inquiétante mais après c'est
c'est c'est aux forces de c'est aux
forces de l'ordre de la caractériser
ainsi pour après déclencher déclencher
l'inquête généralement le les les c'est
c'est là où on voit d'ailleurs toute la
différence entre la la pratique et la
théorie c'est qu'en théorie normalement
on a une première phase dite
administrative on va éplucher les
comptes bancaire on regarde les lignes
téléphoniques bon et ensuite après on
commence là les vrais actes
d'investigation avec des saisies
éventuell de la géolocalisation des des
des des perquisitions même est estce
qu'aujourd'hui est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
mais bon là on voit bien que sur la sur
la pratique on est totalement sur un
champ différent euh aujourd'hui comment
comment vous faites pour vous nous avez
dit c'est les enfants qui vous font
tenir pe mais vous arrivez à à trouver
le sommeil vous arrivez à Imposs
vraiment impossible ah vraiment après je
j'essaie de me reposer parce que bien
sûr vous travaillez le corps il non non
depuis depuis depuis sa dispartion non
ah ouais puis sa disparition non reste
avec les enfants vous êtes à fond focus
sur je suis plus en train de chercher de
trouver des solutions de comment vous
vous cherchiez en fait vous faites
comment vous la vérité je tourne dans la
ville je roule ah ou je suis en de roues
et je je parcours toute la ville vous
avez été forcément dans le 11e
arrondissement où elle a été bord le 11e
dans tous les quartiers de Marseille av
interrogé des personnes des person avec
une photo d'elle et Menz votre propre
enquête quoi voilà et après j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde avec
moi ouais qui m'aide heureusement donc
voilà je je je lesai remerci tous les
jours et euh j'avais une idée de de ce
qui a pu lui arriver ou pas du tout non
du tout rien aucune piste rien aucune
idée zéro piste aujourd'hui je serai à
l'endroit où j'auris une piste vraiment
là aujourd'hui vous vous savez même vous
dites s'il peut je roule à l'aveugle
ouais c'est ça vous êtes inquiet bien
entendu très inquiet plus les jours
passent vous êtes inquiet plus les jours
passent vous dites estce qu'elle va
revenir un jour
euh Gill Henri ça fait maintenant
plusieurs jours que oui que que qu'on a
plus de nouvelles euh là la mobilisation
est extrême hein mobilisation de la
famille il y a des affiches partout dans
Marseille c'est j'ai j'ai j'ai passé des
des des appels à Marseille là les gens
se mobilisent tout le monde est sur les
trace de de mélodie est-ce qu' est-ce
qu' une personne a une dernière personne
qui l'a vu ou un truc quelque chose
comme ça mis à part les enfants c'est la
seule personne c'est seul que je sais
qu'il l'ont vu mais personne pour le
moment il y a pas un témoignage il y a
pas une image après la vidéos surveance
de sortie il y a rien rien de concr
c'est c'est ce qui est le plus dur c'est
qu'on navigue on navigue à l'aveugle
dans l'inconnu totale on ne sait pas
pour quelle raison on ne sait pas où par
qui quoi comment c'est ce qui est le
plus dur c'est le plus dur un pour les
enquêteurs mais aussi pour la famille il
y a pas eu de dispute familial avec vous
il y a ça bien ave ça bien ave très
biens bien ouais voustiez c'était pas le
moment venu de perdre sa mère donc vous
s à fond par rapport à ça moi étaé là
pour mon père donc je suisblé je me dois
d'être là pour
elle écoutez on espère que votre
témoignage ce soir va faire bouger les
choses on espère on voulez vraiment que
vous veniez ce soir pour en parler
l'étape d'après qui peut vraiment
changer les choses c'est si un juge
d'instruction est désigné puisque là les
les pouvoirs d'enquête sont nettement
plus plus élargis avec des des des
possibilités beaucoup plus vastes en
terme de en terme d'enquête en terme de
moyens aussi mobiliser donc ce sera
peut-être l'étape l'étape d'après qui
permettra de de de de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé pe-être merci merci à vous
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là merci tout
de suite au S de la viine sur C 8 merci